[Music]
the world's most pressing issues demand
our attention and Innovation is a way
for us to think outside of the box and
come up with Solutions in a way that is
faster more efficient and allows us to
solve problems with greater success
ysph is really unique in that it's one
of the only schools of Public Health
that has a dedicated program uh for
Innovation so innovate Health Yale was
started in 2013 at yph and it's a way to
really provide students alumni and
faculty who are interested in
challenging and changing public health
issues and we're part of this vibrant
Yale Innovation ecosystem that has
Partners from across Ross campus the
School of Management e Ventures and the
SII Center for Innovative thinking as
well as program Partners uh at the
school of the environment and The
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences and
it's a very supportive environment
because we have funding mentorship and a
collaborative Community across Yale
University to bounce ideas off of meet
partners and that's really how we come
up with a lot of our creative and
innovative solutions innovate healthy Al
has been involved in so many interesting
and groundbreaking Innovations and I'm
happy to provide some examples so KX was
the winner of the 2020 Rita Wilson prize
that was supported by innovate Health
Yale and they use machine learning to
analyze red blood cells to help screen
for disease and they've had a lot of
interesting impacts particularly in
sickle cell and now they're expanding to
other types of blood diseases Rio is a
mental health platform that uses
community-led models of care and it's
really Innovative because they are
helping to support mental health and
well-being but are really taking in the
expertise of the local communities where
they work so to dat innovate Health Yale
has supported over 52 startups operating
in over 30 countries and we've given out
about
$400,000 in Impact grants and the really
exciting thing is that we've seen our
alumni go on to continue to be supported
by Tech Stars the Chan Zuckerberg
initiative Google and leading Venture
Capital
[Music]
firms